we're now on problem number 28
and the question is is x an integer
x an integer
statement 1 tells us
that x over 2 is an integer
so x if you think about it has to be an
integer because x is divisible by 2.
this tells us that x is divisible by 2
because when i divide by 2 it's not like
you know 5.5 or something i get an even
i get a i get an integer so x has to be
an integer and if you want to
use an example well
if x is divisible by 2 then you know x
could be
x would be 6 which is clearly well
anyway that's almost too obvious i don't
think i have to explain this too much
but this alone is enough to know that x
is an integer because it's actually
divisible by two
statement number two tells us
that two x is an
integer this doesn't give me a lot of
information
because
if x is equal to
one-half
then 2x is equal to 1 so x would be so
that 2x is an integer but x is not an
integer but then if x is equal to 1
then 2x is equal to 2
and so 2x being an integer doesn't
necessarily tell me whether or not x is
an integer so this is useless
and this is useful
so the answer is one that only statement
number one is necessary a
problem 29
problem 29 i should write smaller so i
could save space
what is the value of x
simple enough
the first one says 2x plus 1 is equal to
0.
like i said before you could just look
at this and say this is 8th grade
algebra i can solve for x this is all i
need and you could solve for it if you
want you could say 2x
is equal to minus 1 x is equal to minus
1 half but that would be a waste of time
because they're not asking you what x
actually equals they're just asking you
whether you could solve for it
2 says
this is interesting x plus 1
squared
is equal to x squared
now you might be tempted to just take
the square root of both sides but that
actually becomes complicated because you
could have the positive or negative
square roots and you would have to set
up a bunch of different equations the
easiest thing to do would actually be
expand this
so what's x plus 1 squared well it's x
plus 1 times x plus 1 so that's x
squared
plus 2x
plus 1 is equal to x squared
and then if you subtract 2x if you
subtract x squared from both sides of
this equation
you get
2x plus 1 is equal to zero so you
actually end up getting this again so
both of these pieces of information are
equivalent and each of them
independently is enough to solve for x
so the answer is
d each statement alone is sufficient
problem
number
30.
what is the value of 1 over k
plus
1 over r
and what did they give us what
information do they give us
so they tell us that k plus r is equal
to 20
k plus r is equal to 20.
not obvious to me how to figure out
from this what 1 over k plus 1 over r is
and just to experiment if we were to
find a common denominator and add these
together what is another way of writing
this expression
well the common denominator would be kr
and 1 over k is the same thing as r over
kr right
you can cancel out the r's and get 1
over k
plus and 1 over r is the same thing as k
over k r
so this statement is equivalent to this
statement so we're trying to figure out
what r plus k over k times r is
statement 1 just gives us the top so
that by itself isn't enough
what does statement 2 give us
kr
is equal to 64. so statement 2 gives us
this information
right
statement 1 gives us this information up
here
so we actually need both of them to
figure out what this is equal to so the
answer is
c both statements together are
sufficient but individually they're not
that useful
problem 31
if x is equal to one of the numbers
one fourth
3 8
or two fifths
what is the value of x so x is one of
these and we have to figure out which of
they are
okay so statement one tells us
that
one-fourth
is less than x which is less than
one-half
so it immediately cancels if x is
greater than one-fourth statement one
immediately tells us that x is not
one-fourth
and it also let's see and x has to be
less than one half well both of these
numbers are less than one half right
statement one let me do this in a color
statement one
tells us that our answer is either
is one of these two
right that's what statement one tells us
because those both of those right that's
point four that's less than one-half
three-eighths
three-eighths is what
actually no this is interesting
three-eighths is actually greater
3 8 is obviously less than one half
right what do i think 4 8 is exactly one
half so 3 8 is also less than one half
so statement one tells us it's one of
those two choices and then statement two
says that one third
is less than x
which is less than
three
fifths
so this tells us that x has to be
greater than
one
third
so let's see 3 8 is greater than 1 3
right because 3 9
is one third so 3 8 is greater than
one-third
two-fifths
is also greater than one-third right
it's 0.4 so that's greater than
one-third let's see 3 8
is 3 8
less than
three fifths well sure right 3 8
definitely less than three fifths and
two fifths are definitely less than
three fifths so this problem it seems
like problem that statements two and and
one are actually giving you the same
information
and when you get both of them they both
actually don't clarify they don't they
don't give you any clarity whether x is
three eighths or two fifths so they just
leave you hanging and so the answer is
e
together they're still not sufficient
unless i miss something once again
remember i'm just doing this real time i
don't know if
if i'm it's very possible that i
make an error
problem 32
problem 32
triangle pqr
let me draw that
triangle
p
q
r
if p q is equal to x so this distance is
equal to x
and q r is equal to x plus 2 that's
equal to x plus 2.
and pr is equal to y
pr is equal to i which of the three
angles of triangle pqr has the greatest
degree
measure so they want to know which of
these angles so angle one they don't say
two or three but they wanna you need to
be able to figure out which of these
angles has the greatest degree measure
and and it might be intuition to you but
they're essentially in order to figure
out which
angle has the greatest degree measure
you essentially have to figure out which
angle
which angle is opposite the largest side
is
is one way to think about it and that
should get you which is the largest
degree measure so if we could figure out
whether x x plus 2 or y is larger then
we'd be all set so first of all we know
that x plus 2 is greater than y is
greater than x so our answer is as far
as the longest side is either going to
be y or x plus 2
and the shortest side is either going to
be y or x but anyway
what did they say what information they
say 1y
is equal to x plus 3.
so if y is equal to x plus 3 this is the
largest side of the triangle
right this is the largest side of the
triangle this is the second largest
and so that and then this will be
this will
be the if i'm if i'm thinking about this
right
this will be the largest angle
let me think about that
right i mean we could go back to a
little bit of our trigonometry but right
this this would be the largest angle and
let's see so i think one alone is enough
because it tells us that this is the
longest side
this is the longest side the triangle
would look something like this that's
the longest side
that's the second longest side
and then
this would be the shortest side it would
look something like that
and then angle three would be the
longest would be the largest angle
see statement number two tells us that x
is equal to two
x is equal to two gives us no
information about y if we say that x is
equal to 2
then we know that x plus 2 is equal to 4
and we have no information about y so
that really still doesn't help us
because it could easily be a triangle
like this 2
2 and then the 4 could come back this
way
and be like that in which case this
would be the largest angle or y could be
a really big
distance so that 4 could be like that
if y was a really large number
let's see if you have the combination of
the two well i mean we know that one
alone is sufficient two alone is not
sufficient and i'm just doing it let me
think about a little bit let me make
sure that i'm right that one alone is
sufficient yeah i'm pretty sure i mean i
can't think of an example where i have
to know that x is equal to
two
yeah so unless i'm wrong the answer is a
statement
one alone is sufficient i'll see in the
next video